dakota hudson so far in his three starts
been getting the job done we've seen him
be more efficient
throughout so three and two the count
runners at first and second
and the next two o'hern pitch number 17
of the inning
hit the other way could be two out there
wong
a jump stop double play a shift on the
infield and wong still got to the bag
that was ozzie esque jacob junis pitches
for the first time in 19 days paul
goldsmith at the plate now
runner at first takes it the other way
step on the bag and wong hustling to
second
and he's safe by stepping on the bag
took away the force
four for eight with runners in scoring
position is miller
now the pitch and a swing and a miss so
a good start for junas couple of
strikeouts
lead-off single by wong who is stranded
and at the end of one
oils and cardinals no score and with two
outs it's
alberto monteci
line to short andy young makes the play
nothing nothing into the bottom of the
second paul de young
and that is whacked into the glove of
franco he's up and fires a strike over
to first one a play michael franco
franco catches this on the short pick
gets up quick and makes a strong throw
good play
the royals in saint louis nothing
nothing score
third inning nikki lopez shoots it into
left center field and that's down
so the royals for the second time in
three innings have their lead off man on
now the batter cam gallagher gallagher
jolts it into deep left field and it is
going to be gone
into the royals bullpen yes cam
gallagher continues
to take advantage of his playing time
first home run of the year for cam
gallagher and the royals lead it to
nothing cardinals have the top of the
lineup colton wong
they trailed two-nothing and it's a
lead-off walk
junis his first walk of the night tommy
edmond
runner goes and that's a base hit into
right field one to second on his way to
third
and the cardinals have something going
here in their half of the third inning
the aggressive play starting wong and a
base hit for tommy edmond now runners on
first and third
nobody out so here is goldschmidt and
the 1-1 pitch
goldsmith gets underneath it hits it
high in the air
out did deep left at the wall and it is
caught by gordon
just got under it and almost made it a
one-run cardinal lead he
just missed it wong tags up and scores
and it's a 2-1
kansas city lead carpenter who was hit
by a pitch back in the second
and carpenter is hit by the pitch again
so he's been hit
right on the elbow and this time gets
him on the foot
here's a no one and carpenter
off the second and in there safely
dylan carlson has been coming up a ton
with runners in scoring position
carlson slicing down the left field line
that ball is fair
and this game is tied carpenter will
score
carlson sliding into second base with a
double
we're tied to two here's yadier molina
it's a two-hit night for yada yada
molino here's tyler o'neil
go ahead run at first base and yadier
molina
base hit into center so back-to-back
hits
and the rookie a chance again to come
through dylan carlson
and he struck him out looking for
something different number eight
and mcbroom is going to pinch it for cam
gallagher
and that is crushed to left field and
ryan mcbroom
hits another pinch hit home run and he
puts the royals
in front 3-2 in the eighth inning with
merrifield who singled his first time up
and now witt hits it to the gap in right
center field and that's going to be down
and how far will he go that's to the
deepest part of the ballpark
but he will hold at second base and the
royals have a runner at second
alex reyes appeared in five games so far
so it's the second time that ryan
o'hearn has been intentionally walked
and michael franco will be the batter he
is over three
and it's popped up good work by alex
reyes
came in with a runner at second and
nobody out and gets out of it and the
bases are loaded for
dylan carlson for rosenthal seven
for seven in save opportunity and he got
him
didn't mess around did he 97. so the
strikeout of dylan carlson and the woes
of trying to get a runner in from third
and less than two outs so the cardinals
need a two-out hit
here in the bottom of the eighth from
colt wong fastball
struck him out boy you talk about
getting out of a mess it's first and
third for
whitt merrifield and witt hits it well
into left center field but coming over
is o'neill and he misplayed it
and the royals have two huge insurance
runs it is five to two
here's giada molina with two out spaces
loaded the one-two
and yachty is hit by the pitch that'll
score a run
and now a base hit could tie it and
here's tyler o'neill
o'neal hot shot in the left
and this game is tied o'neal has tied it
with two outs here in the bottom of the
ninth we are tied
five five and the bases are loaded
3-1 pitch to colton wong here it comes
and he wants him and this game is over
colton wong
bases loaded walk the cardinals take two
of three
they score four in the bottom of the
ninth
and they win it six to five you kidding
me with them